c'est dommage qu'elle ne vivra pas mais
encore une fois qui fait
plus humain qu'humain est notre devise
J'ai eu environ 200 mots du
monologue qui sort d'un robot
qui manque d'électricité [ __ ]
et il dit aussi que je suis en train de mourir  et il est
le dernier des cinq qui ont été vous savez
bouger en courant et en connaissez-vous
un alors j'ai dit à Ridley depuis le
début nous n'avons pas le temps pour une
bulle
à mon défi pour la dernière scène était
je ferai  deux ou trois choses pendant que la
batterie était déchargée et je vais à peine y arriver
avec trois lignes et je voulais quand je
voulais que Roy dise dans son programme poétique
parce qu'il avait un sens poétique
pour les choses je voulais dire une phrase
pourquoi pourquoi  il est tellement attaché à la vie qu'il a
eu deux lignes dans le script que je
pensais être poétiques d'une manière ou d'une autre et à propos de
vous savez peut-être dans quelque chose de
mouton électrique et puis j'ai trouvé une ligne
tous ces moments seront perdus dans le temps
comme des larmes sous la pluie c'est  la seule ligne que
j'ai et qui était une improvisation  ed qui m'est venu
à quatre heures du matin alors que je
pensais bon sang j'espère qu'ils ne
veulent pas que je dise ces trois autres mots
parce que je pense que ce qui a vraiment dit ouais
tu as raison de
mourir Wiggly et n'avertis pas la mer
attaquer des navires en feu sur l'épaule
hawaïenne
j'ai regardé des poutres en c scintiller dans le noir
près du gâteau Tannhauser
tous ces moments seront perdus dans le temps
comme des larmes
sous la pluie le
temps de mourir
une chose à propos de la colombe était géniale je
pensais que d'accord je mourrai  et puis j'ai aimé que
le chien parte et que le canard agisse pour moi
alors je suis descendu envoyé et nous avons tiré
comme vingt-quatre cinq heures d'affilée et
il pleuvait tout le temps et toi
Douglas dans ma main était dans cette main
sort du  montrez c'est pourquoi il y a
un coup de la star de Dove qui vit soudainement
ce qui le casse un peu pour moi mais
ça marche toujours amusant
vous